Imagine how cool it would be if
we could go back in time and
take classes from the greats?
From Plato, from Maya Angelou,
from Ghandi, from the Wright brothers,
from Einstein.
Even if half of what they said was wrong,
how much would we have improved as
humanity to be able to take what they have
learned and be able to build off that?
[CROSSTALK] I've been curious
since day one in my life.
I got in trouble in school when I
was a kid, asking lots of questions.
I think it's a desire to
understand how the world works and
a realization that life is fragile and
short.
And I want to take advantage of it.
So I've stuttered, I've always stuttered.
It was much worse as a kid and I don't
know, I was teased in school about it.
My parents refused to let me use
that as an excuse for anything.
My parents would always insist that when
they had friends over, I would sit with
them at the dinner table and
I had to participate in the conversation.
So I was always encouraged.
Got it.
At the GSB, I learned about careers and
areas of business that
I didn't know existed.
That was really great in
expanding my worldview.
I think one of the biggest
things I got to just be was,
I learned what my
comparative advantage was.
And I learned how to think in ways.
Yeah, so the story of Masterclass
is one I never expected.
After going to the GSB,
I tried all different ideas,
I thought of all different ideas.
And somebody gave me a great constraint.
She said, choose an idea that even if it
fails, you are going to be proud of it.
That was an awesome constraint for me.
So all the ideas go out
the window except for education.
Masterclass is a set of online classes
from the absolute best in the world.
I had to figure out how to go get
the best in the world to actually teach.
I didn't know how to do it and so
I had literally cold email and cold call.
So the years going by, we aren't
getting any yeses from instructors.
There were dark days in there
where projected belief but
unsure and then also when I get a call.
After we got the first two or three,
it just started to be a chain reaction.
We ended up launching
with five instructors.
It was James Patterson, Dustin Hoffman,
Serena Williams, Usher and
Annie Leibovitz.
Education is the silver bullet.
The only thing we know as a species
that improves life is education.
If somebody who never got exposure to the
best in the world all of a sudden now can
learn from the best,
that can only be good for the world.
There are dark days where you start to
wonder if the critics were actually right.
And then there are days that
are the highest of highs and
days you'd never expected.
I don't want to be on my deathbed and
hopefully in a long time and
think I didn't try to make
the world a tiny bit better.
I don't think Masterclass would be what
it is today if I hadn't gone to the GSB,
the things I learned there I still apply.
It's forced me to believe more in myself,
yeah, and
believe that I could have more impact
than I ever thought I could have, yeah.
[MUSIC]